I want to continue to be a dope example
for people can look at and go wow
look where he came from looking where he
is now I got too many goals trying to
come oh I can't become a mogul are you
doing stupid people are just afraid man
so many people are afraid of rejection
of failure but without failure you have
no success people got choices I hate
that people act like they don't have a
choice you know you got a choice in any
and everything you do need motivation
watch the top 10 with belief nation
what's up at seven my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see explode out under the
world so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew in today's lessons from
a man who went from being a shoe
salesman and being booed off stage early
in his career to becoming a Hollywood
actor and one of the funniest comedians
in the world he's Kevin Hart and here's
my take on his top ten rules success vol
2 enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one
go forward you're a very normal person
you have the same people around you and
I will say that for you I mean it was
the truth yeah well I just said it I
mean how many more times you want me to
say it but you know what do you see I
here's here's what I've learned no I
think the people that have made those
mistakes and that I've went through
those crazy changes within this business
are people that have put themselves in a
position to not grow I think you go
through it at one point but then you go
oh [__] this is bad I messed up one time
I don't want to mess up again I went
through my period I got my DUI I was out
I was drunk every night I was chasing
different women every day of the week I
did that I started they got me nowhere
and then I got focused and I saw her
getting focused got me so why go
backwards you're supposed to progress
and I supposed to digress the man that I
am today is a much more developed man
than I was yesterday and I just don't
see myself wanting to ever lose that I
want to continue to be a dope example
for people can look at and go wow look
where he came from looking where he is
now I got so many goals trying to come
oh I can't become a mogul if you're
doing stupid you gotta you gotta you got
to be responsible enough rule number two
my personal favorite don't be afraid of
failure people are just afraid man so
many people are afraid of rejection of
failure but without failure you'd have
no success what was the one that stung
the most as far as failures we're stuck
the most biggest failure I had a TV show
called the big house got picked up by
ABC they told me that we were gonna do
12 episodes flew me down to New York
this is the biggest news ever
I'm about to be rich holy I'm 22 I got a
TV show I'm writing executive producing
starring in the show you know what no
I'm not just gonna go down there by
myself we got to bring the cash they
said no Kevin we only flying you I said
well I'm a pay for the cast to come I
took my own money through them all down
in New York get to New York put on my
suit people taking pictures of me
walking out this is the best thing ever
holy SH I'm famous this is what it is I
get to the up front up front to where
they announce your TV show so slew of
shows there
their time slots I'm next there Bob
announced the big house somebody puts
their hand on my chest and says Kevin
wait they talking to earpiece they said
nope I'm standing with him right now
I'm like what's going on would they want
me to do you know they want me go on the
other side or something he goes okay
I'll tell him they cancel they're not
gonna pick you up you got a step back
and I was like that don't sound right
literally that fast they sent me home
they're like you gotta just go home TV
show got picked up six months later for
six episodes the third episodes air they
cancel show again I got the show can't
do twice in a six-month period which has
never been done before I've booked about
three more pilots got cancelled there
was a show called John Stamos his show
he was a publicist and they wanted me as
a series regular the show was going
great ratings were good put me on the
show show got canceled it was everything
got touched on TV tundish I'm now just
sitting out here doing nothing
I handle money borrow money left and
right I decided to say [__] it I said
I'm just gonna do stand-up comedy and
focus on my craft and I slaved the role
for about five years
doing the same circuit over and over
again rule number three choose
positivity people got choices I hate
that people act like they don't have a
choice you know you had a choice in any
and everything you do here's one thing
that I'll say to your listeners and when
I say just think about it do you know
how much energy and time it takes to be
angry do you know how much time it takes
to hold a grudge to really muster up the
energy to hold on to a grudge I don't
like you every time I see you I gotta
let you know I don't like you I don't
like you that's energy right I'm
throwing I'm throwing all this stuff I'm
throwing all this stuff your way and
that's energy that I could use to going
to something else like I when I think
about my time I think about my energy I
think about my efforts how much time and
energy do I really have and how much do
I want to put into stuff that's not
going to affect me on a day-to-day basis
just negative just nonsense nonsense I
mean would I don't
the time for it that's why the
negativity that the negativity that I
have received I respond with commas rule
number four ask yourself what now
why did you know you're special what now
any entertainer with longevity always
gets the question of what now oh my god
shows she had a great show okay what now
right right what what what do you'll do
now what now oh my god last season was
great what now what do you what are we
gonna do now what do you want to do
Chelsea your last stand-up tour is
amazing what now
it's a question that you should never
stop getting but you should also never
stop having an answer for it so I made
it the title because in all of my
stand-up I've put my life and my life
experiences in them you see me grow from
grown little man to seriously funny to
laugh for my pain - let me explain - now
what now well I'm always trying to outdo
myself so I posed the question for
everyone else
what now with you I know what I'm doing
I know the direction I'm going in but I
love to inspire and to motivate so that
question should be a question that
everybody gets after school after work
after any and everything you do what now
and it's just big it's just so simple
but yet so complex I don't think people
really put a full understanding into the
meaning of the answer to what now it
should just be ongoing so my career is
ongoing just like the question of what
now it's pretty dope isn't it rule
number five gamble on yourself what
sparked the idea to do to do stadiums it
was watching these performers Beyonce's
jay-z's Justin Timberlake Taylor Swift
you look at all these musicians and they
go out and they put on these big
productions they put on these big shows
and I was like nobody does that for
comedy
you know everybody everybody does the
same thing when it comes to stand-up
comedy they come out as a microphone and
it's a curtain you know so I said what
if I make my shows an event what if I
put a production behind my shows what if
I bring a different level of creativity
to stand-up comedy to almost make it a
rock and roll like event and it was a
vision that I had that I shared some
people didn't understand which made me
go and say
get out I'll do it myself you know
that's where having the the mindset to
literally gamble on yourself do what you
want to do always comes in handy because
sometimes being a visionary isn't
something that everybody can identify
with you know sometimes people only see
one way and down one Street I saw a
street that opened up into so many
different paths and different lanes and
I just wasn't afraid to take the chance
and a football stadium was also
groundbreaking you know I don't want to
do something and not be known for what I
did in my generation I want to stand out
so why not try to make history which is
why I did the football stadium you know
52,000 people is nothing to be frowned
upon but what you gotta look at as a
comedian has never done it so it was all
about making a stamp in an imprint in
today's generation rule number six grind
what I had to understand was that you
you're not in competition with with
anybody but yourself so those those
grudges you know those those reasons
that you may give yourself a motivation
ultimately are you know they're they're
pointless right mad at you I'm gonna
prove you wrong all right well when I
prove you wrong then what what happens
I'm so me right yes I don't that there
is no winning it so I had to understand
that if I'm gonna stay true to what I
feel that I can do then I need to be the
one to convince myself that this is what
I'm supposed to be doing but a lot of
people can't don't has that bounced back
so you don't have a lot of a lot of
people that you know make it to a
certain successful point in life there's
a lot of people a lot of people can give
up is easy to give up you know yeah it's
the easiest thing in the world to do I'm
I'm I'm done ain't going oh yeah I gonna
keep going yeah that's what I gonna work
so one
yeah I'm hazy it's very easy but what's
hard is going you know yesterday I got
nothing from working as hard as I could
nothing happened from that I'm gonna do
the same thing again a day but I'm gonna
try to go harder that's the hardest
thing in the world to get up every day
and give a hundred percent and and be in
the same
position that you were each day but
mentally know that you're trying and
trying and trying that's that's a real
that's a real grind rule number seven
surround yourself with greatness let's
answer the question okay yeah yeah the
question is what keeps us together thank
you for staying focused okay here's the
thing
I'm very I'm very strong and believing
and the group that you keep around you
is a representation of who you are we
keep a solid group around us and our
group carries a responsibility of not
being funny well told you judge him
we are literally have grown together and
I think when you get to see your crew
really become successful within their
own rights and they can branch out with
new things as a representation of who
you guys are as a unit and we look back
and we look at the road and that circle
that we have
nobody's pop that bubble we don't allow
other people to come into it because we
have such a unique bond and a way that
we move and if somebody else comes into
it alters what we did rule number eight
develop thick skin you know I think we
all take body blows in the entertainment
business you
there's always something that happens
that makes you go oh like damn like
there's a there's there's moments where
you got to take the knee Lucian was the
first person to put me down to where I
had to take me he was he was basically
he told me that I needed to find
something else to do you know it was
that blunt I got offstage I had a great
set
you know granted my material wasn't sure
great material I'm new I'm green but I
had a great set the crowd enjoyed me and
I thought that I was going to the back
to talk to him about coming to the comic
strip and doing spots and instead it was
just I don't see it I don't see this
being your craft you know I I think that
you should definitely look into doing
something else because this isn't this
isn't it this isn't this isn't for you
and that's the first time that I heard
that but I had a guy like
'if that I was so close to that I told
him and I'm expected to keep him like
damn a blue she said that it's it's
something and he was like I've collusion
so what come on stupid let's go down to
the cellar get some meat and I was like
eat I can't yeah at a time like this my
life is over shut up stupid he's getting
a car and we'll go to other comedy clubs
pollution like he was so it was so
nonchalant and it rolled off his back
and when I saw that I was like I was
still affected by it but I was like man
I don't know how exact like this is no
big deal this is me this is my career it
is a big deal didn't we get down to the
cellar and everybody there is just so
what whatever and we all were so vicious
to each other and we all were so mean to
each other
but what we really did was prepare each
other for the word knowing I could come
at any possible time we made each other
comfortable with the fact that we we
were okay we're gonna be okay
rule number 9 nurture good relationships
my one thing is you better stay true to
in his businesses relationships you know
you're gonna meet a lot of people and in
Hollywood everybody appears to be real
men but it's a facade you got to be a
great character and a great judgment of
character you know everybody loves you
when things are going great but you
really get to see who you are who the
real people around you are when things
aren't and those people that you can
tell of real you hold on to you know you
stayed true to those relationships
because there's gonna come to a point
where you go damn what do I have out
here what substance do I have out here
if it's not a party it was not a
nightclub if you're not in a
relationship what matters it's only
gonna be about a good five or six people
to actually matter and those five or six
people are gonna be there for you
whenever you need them
and the favors that I called on those
are long-term relationships man but I
don't have many you know I got friends
in the business that are really my
friends but I pride myself on the 10 to
12 that I have because they're genuine
they're real everything else just comes
off as an associate it's something that
moves when you move in a high-end buy
but those real ones are real for a
reason because when you call Davis
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is have fun
we're back with Kevin Hart and we are
playing Jenga and you said during the
break that you heard that I was a
cheater I didn't know I am NOT Vardhan I
am competitive but I will never cheat
listen Ellen what black people take
games like this very serious okay
don't cheat well then consider me black
Joey I don't I feel the same way
okay now Matt because because wit this
needs to be like a speed Ginga so don't
take too long
yeah and we're going one hand you want
to go first I'll go for out one hand one
hand go I'll go first
go strategy tire training strategy my
[__] all right my pieces out put your
piece on the top
one hand out okay that's gonna fall
that's gonna fall that's still gonna
fall
everybody knows don't go to the bottom
everybody knows that
[Applause]
[Music]
okay and a certain point guys I'm gonna
need a stool to put the pieces back that
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
No why do you want to end the game
strategy to this game cuz I started it I
can't cheat Ellen I shouldn't did this
piece stupid kid well there it goes and
[Music]
there's no way it's gonna stay
do not do that to my piece right now it
doesn't matter how slow if I get this
piece we head back so no it's it's not
it's gonna fall
[Applause]
[Music]
now I've got a special bonus clip from
Kevin Hart on how to overcome obstacles
but before that I want to know what was
the biggest lesson that you learned from
this video what did you take away that
you were going to apply somehow to your
life or your business leave it down the
comments below I want to hear from you
and when you write it down it's much
more likely to actually happen in your
life so put it in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
my Road is a road of hardship you know
sir it's a lot of [__] that I went
through to get to where I am today a lot
of violence you saw I didn't know you
saw that kind of violence growing up
yeah yeah my dad my dad was a cookie man
because he is a cab yeah he did a lot so
I'm sure your father was bleeding for me
hacked up with an axe
my dad got hidden here with axe what
when I went over to his house to go see
him which my mom hated to do cuz her
fear was we don't know what happens over
there and one of the times when she was
like fine go my dad got in a fighting a
guy hit my dad in here with X he came
back with a towel towel was ful fully
blood like there's no white left in the
towel then had a logical explanation and
that was refrigerator repairman right
guy was jealous because I was better and
he hit me with dads do you think that's
the real reason no but back then when
you're kid it makes sense oh yeah oh god
dad well you got to stop being so good
at refrigerator he just wanted to take
the opportunity and self a pat on the
back
what was that literally like I mean
between that between sitting seeing my
dad get jumped me and my brother saw my
dad get jumped and before it happened he
was like y'all go home I'm about to
whoop these guys ass clearly knew that
it was gonna go the other way do you
think he won't be whip their asses know
who came back came back and the results
were obvious so what happened he got a
beating he didn't even acknowledge it
he's like you're hungry look at you man
you all right doesn't scare you when you
see your father because your father is
like such a strong figure in your life
and does it scare you when you see a
strong figure like that be beaten up
it's it's a different level of reality
as a child like your dad is a hero you
know there's nothing that your dad can't
do your dad say you can do it as a kid
you believe if I say hey y'all want to
see me jump on this roof yeah
all right everybody back up whether I do
it or not my kids are the only people
out there it's like dad's gonna do it
yeah they have nothing but belief that
you can do what you say you can do so
when you start to see the the guy that
you saw that was instant invincible and
your mind you start to see those layers
get
the way it does have an effect you know
it is like damn like dad is not who we
thought dad was not a superhero lies and
steel yeah a lot of you just thought
your dad was this amazing refrigerator
repairman who beat her buddy up they're
like no he's not no he's not no he's
just my dad does drugs and steals
refrigerators if I could complete
obviously I never resented my dad that's
a tough word never I never I don't have
any level of hate you know of course
there was disappointment there was high
levels of damn I thought dad was coming
to pick us up today or damn man we ain't
seen dad and I don't know how long he's
not picking up the phone he's not
answering the calls you know there's a
there's a love of love what's going on
with dad it was never a thing where it
was like my daddy I don't I don't have
that any I never have and my mom never
talked like that to help ignite a flame
that would put that in me so when he
went through his problems he went to him
on his own until my brother felt that I
was old enough to handle information and
he told me dad's on drugs it is what it
is you know we can't help him till he
wants to help himself and my dad had
resentment in a grudge because my dad
stole from my brother you know my
brother was building his barbershop and
he brought all the equipment he wanted
my dad to do the electrical work just to
kinda help your dad get back at his feet
help him get on his feet put some money
in his pocket
and my dad was doing the job for a
minute and then we come back one day
everything was gone my dad stole
everything and that's my brother didn't
look like it went black for my brother
at that so it took me talking to my
brother to get my brother to forgive so
we can finally get my dad help raise
your standard Apple at the pool his core
value
is that we believe that people your
passion can change the way that not one
drop of my self-worth depends on your
it's supposed to mean I don't ever give
up I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
rows of success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details